tous
faux profil sur facebook comment les
détecter twitter instagram facebook
chaque média social contient son lot de
faux profils et c'est loin d'être un
phénomène marginal sur facebook des
millions de faux comptes de s'ancrer à
tous les jours seulement dans les trois
premiers mois de 2010 8
l'entreprise a éliminé près de 600
millions de faux profils imaginer soit
près du quart de son nombre
d'utilisateurs actifs qui se chiffrait
alors à près de 2 milliards de profil
qu'est ce qui motive ce qui se cache
derrière ses faux profils
parmi les possibilités ma premièrement
obtenir des données personnelles qui
valent très cher c'est en fait une
véritable industrie
deuxièmement les faux profils peuvent
être un puissant outil de désinformation
alors qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
quand vous avez un doute sur un profil
facebook
conseil numéro 1 fait parler la photo de
profil comme il est fréquent de voir les
auteurs de faux profils et récupéré la
photo d'une personne réelle connus ou
inconnus mais une recherche inversée sur
google image est très utile à elle seule
cette recherche vous permettra peut-être
de prouver le subterfuge et de voir qui
est la personne dont l'identité a été
utilisé
conseil numéro 2 scruter les amitiés
facebook si le nombre d'amis facebook du
poids fils en question où vous apparaît
très très faible ou si ses amis sont
dispersés un peu partout dans le monde
sans lien évident où loger qu'entre ma
méfiez vous si vous n'avez pas accès à
la liste d'amis du profil dont vous
doutez
rabattez vous sur l'activité est allé
sur le mur facebook
s'il ya très peu de traces d'activités
ou de communication entre le profil
suspect et ses amis là encore
méfiez-vous conseil numéro trois les
questions pièges plus délicat mais non
moins efficace ce conseil consiste à
poser des questions simples directs et
stratégiques à la personne derrière le
potentiel faux profils des questions par
exemple sur des détails géographiques
entourant son lieu de naissance de
résidence ou encore de travail
tout ça pour tester la validité des
informations mises de l'avant
mais peu importe les conseils un peu
plus technique qu'on peut vous donner
il y en a vraiment qui est très
important un bon vieux conseil suivez
votre instinct